in this javascript tutorial we're going
to be coding tic-tac-toe or more
specifically we'll be coding tic-tac-toe
with minimax algorithm using HTML and
vanilla JavaScript the code is all
available online on github so take a
look if you're interested I'll include a
link in the description below anyway
well we'll go over today is the basic
implementation of tic-tac-toe and HTML
and vanilla JavaScript as I said before
we'll cover various parts of the code
I'll go into more detail on my thought
process and goals for each function
follow up with the minimax
implementation which is what we're using
for the AI it's how it decides which
move to make and what you'll notice with
a working minimax implementation is that
the AI is perfect
it plays flawlessly to a victory or draw
every single time it's not possible to
win and we'll see why shortly to begin
the index dot HTML is pretty bare
there's a bit of CSS up here but that's
relatively unimportant beyond
controlling some looks for the game
there's no logic tied to anything up
there so I won't go over it you're free
to change the look however you want the
body is relatively bare we have three
divs here one is the header which just
has the tic-tac-toe title at the top so
if you look on the right in the in
chrome you'll see the tic-tac-toe title
one is the description which is just
where the game will output whether or
not you want or lost so once you play
the game you know just play quickly so
you can see that this text pops up here
and finally you have this Rose div which
is going to act as the container for all
of the squares on the board we're gonna
do here is programmatically create them
using document create element and then
place them as children of the Rose div
so let's go look at the code
the first thing we do is listen for Dom
content loaded and then call our setup
function from there
setup is relatively simple all we're
looking to do is create the board and
start the game so the board is a
standard tic-tac-toe game consisting of
nine squares so we're gonna do a nested
loop of three rows by three columns
we'll create three devrai's which will
act as containers for the rows and then
we'll insert each square element into
those containers and finally we'll add
that container to the div from the
index.html file now you could of course
go and define a whole bunch of divs in
index.html instead of programmatically
doing this there's nothing wrong with
that approach you just need to go into
the index.html and define nine divs and
give them appropriate names we did this
programmatically because that gives us
potentially some flexibility down the
road also if you're watching this and
you're looking to improve your
JavaScript skills you might as well try
and write the code to do this anyway
theoretically since you're doing this
all via code you could have a board
that's not just three by three you could
go four by four or ten by ten or 100 by
hundred or however big you want we're
not going to but we could and I may just
do that as a follow up the other thing
to call out here is the onclick handler
which we set for every image element and
what this does is we get a callback
every time one of the squares is clicked
on and that gives us a way for the
player to take their turn let's go look
at the code for this every time the
player clicks on one of the squares we
get this handle player click a callback
and what it does is it checks a few
things it checks whether or not the
square was blank whether or not the game
is still running and whether or not it's
the players turn if it is it changes the
square to an X and then calls the AI
this is the entry point for the AI and
it runs the minimax implementation but
also point out that there's this
highlight squares part that is what
happens when you click here so let's
just go over here and you click and you
notice that it takes a second and it
I like some things and it animates and
that's all that does yeah if you take it
away you just get instant feedback so
it's not strictly necessary for the
functionality of the game it's just
there as a visual thing to you know try
and look a little better as I said the
AI uses a minimax implementation to make
its choice for which move to make before
we get into that let's do a walk-through
of the minimax algorithm in general so
the minimax algorithm is a recursive
algorithm used for finding the optimal
move for the player the assumption being
that the other player will also play
optimally choosing moves that counter
yours or and move them towards a
possible victory now one player is
considered the Maximizer and the other
one is the minimizer
meaning that one player is assumed to be
maximizing their score while the other
is countering or doing things to
minimize the score since tic-tac-toe is
simple and pretty much a win-lose
proposition the score in this case is 1
or negative 1 the Maximizer is working
towards 1 or victory while the minimizer
is choosing moves that ideally result in
them winning or the Maximizer losing so
that's negative 1
going through an example assuming you're
looking at this board and it's always
turned it's easy to see that the Oh
player would choose the top right but
why the way minimax works is that you'll
start by trying out every possible move
and in this case there are three
possible moves which we've shown here as
the algorithm tries each one out one of
them results in victory while the others
result in X's turn the algorithm has to
check each one out and choose the best
one the one that results in the best
score so we'll have to unroll this a bit
to see the full decision-making process
now since the algorithm has to check out
all the possibilities from the first
board there are two possible moves that
X can make and from the second board
there are another two possible moves
that X can make none of these results in
a victory for X at least at this time so
what would happen is that we would
recurse again this time trying positions
for you again we're not going to keep
drawing these but you can see that in
four of the four cases Oh still wins all
roads lead to victory in this case but
at this level of the tree X was trying
to find moves that are resulted in a win
or a draw for X now looping back to the
code looping back to the code here's the
minimax function I've written it really
verbose Li trying to make it as readable
as possible so you could make it more
succinct I chose not to you can see here
that if it's the AI Stern then the AI is
going to be the Maximizer it's trying to
find moves that maximize the score that
is it chooses moves that results in
victory or worse to draw let's go look
at the minimax maximize function so the
way that the maximize function works is
that there's a loop that looks at every
blank space on the board and it poses a
what if I moved here question then it
recursively calls minimax to check out
how the player would respond if you were
to make that move so over here it copy
is the game state and then says well
what if I moved what if I put an O here
what would happen how would the player
respond so here it calls minimax again
but this time it's the players turn and
it's made its move and it wants to know
how the player would
potentially respond given that move and
the players goal is to minimize the
score so the player is gonna choose the
the move that best benefits the player
and this is gonna recurse again and
again and again it's gonna go back to
the AI back to the player until it
reaches a victory or a draw state for
somebody and then after looking at all
the nodes trying to find the ones that
result in victory or worse to draw the
AI is eventually going to settle on the
best move given the current state of the
board so assuming the player chooses
moves that benefit them and they I
choose this moves the benefit then the
move is propagated back up and then we
flip the tile now we do a quick check to
see whether or not the game has ended
the way this works as we evaluate the
board for a winner
all over looking for is three in a row
for either player if there's no winner
and they're still moved left to be made
and the controller's return to the
player who can then make their turn
and since minimax is working properly on
this board it's not possible to beat the
AI that's let's just go and try
you
you can see that no matter which squares
you choose you're not gonna beat the AI
the best you can hope for is a draw the
problem here is that tic-tac-toe isn't
complex and the AI can exhaustively
search for every move in existence
seeing seven eight nine moves ahead of
it needs to and deciding on a course of
action based off of that once you get
into bigger boards like if we switched
this to 5 by 5 or 100 by 100 or more
complex games like chess then you'll
need to start pruning away some of the
options and using heuristics instead of
exhaustive search but in this case the
AI has perfect knowledge of every
possibility and it cannot be beaten so
if you found this informative then give
it a like and subscribe and I'll see you
next time Cheers
you